[Music]
in response to the tragedy of world war
ii people from the town Reggio Emilia
developed a new model of education war
Orton never happened again
led by Loras malaguti a teacher their
idea was to enhance a child's learning
through real-life experiences instead of
a fixed curriculum so that each child
develops a love for discovery forms a
personality of their own and learns to
respect others land money food and
skills for the first preschool were
provided by the community the Reggio
Emilia
approach is based on the philosophy of
an image of a child all children are
viewed full of potential with an innate
sense of curiosity and endless
imagination they are creative capable of
constructing their own learning and they
have a natural interest to explore while
they follow their own interests they
also stay connected with others adults
nurture their learning by providing a
rich environment and support instead of
a one-size-fits-all curriculum Reggio
Emilia uses a child centered approach
and project-based learning projects can
emerge anytime for example during play
teachers can observe and create
opportunities for new learning at a
specific instance for example by opening
up new environments letting children
raise thought-provoking questions or by
inviting others to collaborate after an
intervention the children take control
and progress independently until the
project is finished and can be shared
with others throughout a project
children naturally embody the spirit of
researchers risk takers designers and
explorers they make hypotheses try new
things
investigate play and imagine to progress
the Explorers raise the questions the
researchers give feedback and the
designers demonstrate ideas and
prototypes
lastly they all turn their theories into
reality and construct experiments
together the learning becomes social
with endless ways to solve specific
problems to promote the development of
creativity teaches step aside and let
mistakes happen the conflicts that can
follow nurture their social skills
because conflicts teach children to
speak to listen to argue and to discuss
then learn to accept different opinions
and to respect others for who they are
if two kids discuss a problem a third
can have an idea and the entire group
learns the value of teamwork teachers
document projects through pictures
videos or written observations the
learnings become visible in photographs
drawings or sculptures ideas quotes and
transcripts of conversations are put
onto the walls the children can later
revisit their achievements see projects
that were left unfinished and learned
that failure is part of the path to
progress they built confidence in their
own abilities but teachers aren't
instructors instead they are companions
in the child's own journey of discovery
they can introduce books show new tools
or offer entirely new perspectives
however they always remain mindful not
to take over the constructive learning
process knowing that this limits a
child's endless imaginations and
motivation the children are fully in
charge and develop a sense of ownership
of their own progress the foundation for
a love for lifelong learning malaguti
believe that there are 100 languages
children can use to express themselves
they paint sculpt drum whisper and hark
they build listen speak or sing and
dance and they play which Einstein
allegedly said is the highest form of
research
children learn from adults other
students the environment which is
regarded as the third teacher rich in
materials the space is designed to spark
curiosity creation and discovery
ideally there is an open kitchen and big
windows so the children can see what's
happening outside just like it an
Italian town square of the answer where
we can observe the lives of other
members of our community parents are
regarded is the last part of this
education to deepen their knowledge of a
child centered education they are
encouraged to learn from and with the
teachers and children so when the
children come home after school they can
continue to be researchers risk takers
and explorers malaguti once said stand
aside for a while and leave room for
learners observe carefully what children
do and then if you have understood well
perhaps teaching will be different from
before maybe one day our small
researchers and explorers will grow into
the big inventors and great explorers
[Music]
millions of students from all around the
globe have watched our sprouts videos
for better learning thousands of
teachers play them in their classrooms
to start projects volunteers on YouTube
have translated them to over 25
languages our mission is to promote
learning by doing in classrooms around
the world if you are a great explainer
and a passionate teacher and you want to
help us develop outstanding content
contact us to support our channel with a
donation visit patreon.com slash sprouts